[Musique]
tout juste quelques mois à la fin du
journal on n'a pas eu le temps que même
s'ils pensent surclasser une sorte de
psa
bon en gros je t'explique c'est des
scientifiques français ont trouvé un
moyen de quantifier l'amour parce que
les analystes y avait quelques tests
ensuite ils sont capables à l'idée de
mieux quantifier ton amour quoi d'accord
d'accord pour agir au moment de mettre
du concret et gouvernement a autorisé le
truc on peut faire le test
justement patrick veux tu parles de ça
en gros on cherche des volontaires pour
les premiers tests et si ça se passe
bien et là ce sera autorisée pour tout
le monde est ok bon je vais pouvoir me
caler sa
[Musique]
les ont toutes fait le buzz ah oui le
test d'amour à paron wasa qua non non
non ça comme ça enfin parme m enfin oui
c'est très bien c'est pourquoi mais bon
mais vous cgt pas sûrs de notre coup je
t'aurais pas dans mariage je sais c'est
les gens le font pour pour le fun
peinture c'est vrai ça m'est égal je
on y va ouais
[Musique]
la gamme
la journée
il a souri
[Musique]
où
oh
[Musique]
où
oh
[Musique]
m
en
[Musique]
à
oh
on
pas trop
veuillez répondre aux questions
suivantes instinctivement le plus
rapidement possible d'accord non
contraignant ferrand mélo profession je
savais craint les rations écrivant
croyez vous à nous oui croyez vous à
l'amour éternel
distinguez vous l'amour de l'affection
dix stades et vous l'amour de
l'affection nos parents sont ils ont
créé ensemble ouais avez vous déjà été
infidèles
non avez vous déjà pensé à être infidèle
avez vous déjà pensé à être infidèle nom
de considérer comme possessif
vous considérez vous comme possessif
notez bien souvent à votre amant à votre
amante avec des shows les vaches y avait
des choses à cacher non avez vous des
choses à cacher non
[Musique]
merci
ça s'est vu
ouais ouais je passe bientôt se venge
l'effet faut attendre le médecin
l'algérie en tickets
alors on a les résultats enfin des
estimations des quoi les estimations
alors je vous explique un ces tests ne
sont pas à prendre au pied de la lettre
en tout cas pas pour l'instant et les
résultats reflètent l'état de l'amour
que vous portez l'un à l'autre à ce jour
les résultats peuvent être différent si
vous revenez demain par exemple l'amour
varie constamment c'est pas une une
valeur linéaire pour ombrer d'accord
alors ce que j'ai sous les yeux c'est le
résultat grâce eu 1 c'est le résultat
simpliste des analyses pour pouvoir
avoir des résultats beaucoup plus
complet il ya des frais supplémentaires
des analyses en laboratoire et ses accès
donc d'après ce que j'ai sous les yeux
côté pour moi ça a l'air d'aller
vous aimez soyez pas de doute telle tête
était deux je peux pas vous dire à
combien de pourcentage par exemple
madame et monsieur ou monsieur et madame
pour sabah il faudrait avoir les
résultats qu'on met donc c'est bien
c'est bien les résultats sont donc quoi
ah oui oui alors le seul détail c'est
qu'ils sont bien avoir une tierce
personne dans notre dans votre histoire
là commença alors j'ai dit il semble y
avoir une tierce personne j'ai compris
c'est à dire quoi ça veut dire qu'un ou
deux qu'on dira l'un de vous deux
exprimerez de l'amour pour une
je sais pas pour plus de détails là il
faudrait avoir les résultats complets ne
pas être un bug c'est combien alors
étant donné que le test n'est pas encore
public là vous bénéficiez de la formule
la plus accessible
celle où les recherches en fait sur le
temps libre des chercheurs vous aurez un
résultat dans l'est dans les trois mois
on va dire en revanche vous avez la
formule plus complète comme celle ci un
qui l'a vous permet d'avoir un résultat
complet en seulement quelques heures un
loyer donc là il ya le charabia médical
puis la synthèse très clair qui vous
permet d'avoir un résultat c'est combien
de coups d'informer ses 1500 euros et ça
c'est dans trois mois alors abaissé
celle ci 1000 1500 euros ah non la
formule express ses 6000 on abat merci
beaucoup mais on va s'en passer en s'en
passerait pas par ce que ça représente
le budget notre mariage voilà pourquoi
ça sert à rien
[Musique]
oui bon
ça va m ou nicole cooke ou na waie
oui oui vous voulez quoi
[Musique]
oui merci beaucoup et on prépare bien là
on a presque fini
on est en voiture la wii sous la route
on vous rappelle ce soir pourquoi tu es
méchant comme ça avec eux je suis pas
méchant débat riche en mets de la
pression que les demandes de trois
nouvelles c'est bon pour leur redonner
ses équipes et où le mariage
[Musique]
mais si vous voyez passer c'est l'acteur
qui joue dans game of thrones et il est
aussi en seigneur des anneaux sean penn
schoen bin voila et berrichonne been
il meurt dans tous les films il meurt et
il meurt super bien chez nous vivons là
du coup récemment au cinéma j'ai pas
dans la norme est de voir des films je
m'endors ça va madame j'aime que les
transformers
pas vraiment je vous souhaite
[Musique]
bon
beaucoup
[Musique]
oh
demain
moment de mon
mon
[Musique]
et voilà la salle avec son charme très
atypique
c'est vraiment une perle rare dans le
domaine de la réception ont pensé mettre
la grande scène à droite à côté des
portes et des tables un peu partout dans
la salle qu on enlèverait ensuite pour
laisser place au dancefloor
d'ailleurs quand vous passez le numéro
du dj quand vous m'avez parlé que je
prenne ses coordonnées voilà le panneau
qui est arrivé aujourd'hui c'est tous
pour votre chèque d'aujourd'hui alors ça
va pas trop stressé là on n'a pas le
temps d'être stressé un grand froid sans
quoi ton ton rire là et on sourira ça
c'est nouveau c'est faux cul c'est quoi
de quoi tu parles
alors tu me fais ça depuis des semaines
qu'est-ce qu'il ya encore ton ex est en
boîte je t'ai vu avec lui il était la
ville où j'allais pas l'ignorer c'est
pas lui tombeau des sms toute la journée
par hasard ça appelé toit et non tu
caches ton téléphone ça c'est nouveau ça
va avec le rire le sourire de merde ça
cause du test tu prends la tête à cause
des réseaux et bien sûr tous du test
résultats senti qu'on pouvait bien sûr
milou le gall a dit c'est une première
version t'es con ou quoi
et pourtant
ne prend pas en compte ces têtes je te
jeu je vois comment toi tu peux tu
imaginer des parce que tu crois
[Musique]
j'attends la fin
non
[Musique]
si vous voulez bien parfait et signe à
la dernière page et vous plaît
[Musique]
on
on attend tous
[Musique]
merci beaucoup à tous attendus dans les
deux heures de jeu
satisfait tu sais tout là tu veux savoir
autre chose l'asie posera des questions
je t'écoute là je vais être l'annoncé
pendant le mariage ça aurait été beau
nom allemand
non parce que si monsieur sait pas tout
surtout avec les god monsieur oeuvre que
suite à sa crise parce que ce que
monsieur a toujours tout ce qu'ils
voulaient et moi par contre on s'en bat
les couilles tu peux aller me faire
[ __ ]
tu te demander une seule fois comment je
vais le mariage pression l'organisation
tu m'a pas demandé une seule fois
comment ça allait me sens comme une
merde voilà à devoir dépendre de toi et
ta famille parce que ses équipes et où
je me sens comme une merde a pas pouvoir
t'aider à écrire ton bouquin à pattes
inspiré mais tout ce que tu trouves à
faire pour cette période c'est pas
simple test pour savoir à quel point on
serait compatible
je sais mais je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire ce résultat une tierce personne
j'en sais rien peut-être que parfois oui
je pense à mon ex avec qui j'ai passé
six ans de ma vie
voilà ce que c'est une relation qui m'a
aidé et qui m'a forgé qui m'a construite
mais c'est pas de l'amour c'est
l'attachement c'est de la fiction c'est
toi que j'aime
jeu au maximum la jeu c'est tout ce que
je peux t'offrir tu veux pas de moi
trouve quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
monsieur vos résultats
moi
mo
[Musique]
beau
non
homo
oh
[Musique]
personne
le
oh
[Musique]